imagine a pool of Middle Eastern oil
money the size of US budget for public
transportation and education combined
and all of that money is entrusted to
Japanese businessmen who constantly
talks about starting some kind of a
revolution that's basically a vision
fund in a nutshell for us in the media
who cover a vision fund daily it's kind
of easy to forget how insane and unusual
this whole thing is it was kind of a
shocker when Masayoshi Son announced the
vision fund and his plans to raise a
hundred billion dollars to invest in the
tech space it's the largest technology
investment fund ever 100 billion dollars
well that was saying everybody to buy
things man that's a lot it made bets on
a spectrum of startups from AI to
ride-sharing apps to division funds
biggest investments uber and we work
causing investors to wonder if masses
efficient fund is starting to show some
cracks Softbank the Japanese corporation
that runs the controversial vision fund
reported a record operating profit last
year with the vision fund as its best
performer but bad investments and the
global pandemic have changed everything
in May the vision fund reported a 17
billion dollar loss contributing to the
biggest loss in softbank's history the
vision fund at this point has lost more
money for so Bank that in made
[Music]
[Applause]
Masayoshi son is a very impressive
entrepreneur from Japan us educated
actually got an engineering degree at
the University of California Berkeley
started a few companies while in school
by the time he moved back to Japan in
his early 20s he had all these business
projects going built up his empire from
there he is willing to take risks a lot
of risks including in the first dot-com
boom and bust around 2000 he placed a
big bet on Alibaba and almost everything
he had got wiped out except Alibaba at
the bottom of the crash
I actually revived my spirits of the
fighting
Softbank is now one of the biggest
companies in the world it's a
conglomerate they have lots of interests
in mobile phones and they started this
investment fund a few years ago where a
rival of vision fund software group was
dramatically reshaped it was reshaped as
a holding company with investing at its
core business now as to what Suns vision
I mean I think he has a really keen
sense of these cresting ways of
technological change and he wants
something to be the company that not
only survives these sort of cataclysms
but also emerges as a key player and key
investor and the companies who will go
on to run the world so when you told
people you were gonna raise a hundred
billion dollar fund did they tell you
you were a little crazy
well some people said the thing about
soft banks vision fund is it was bigger
bolder grander than
anyone had ever seen before Suffolk
itself is a big investor but its biggest
investor by far is the public investment
fund of Saudi Arabia you had a meeting
with a man who was the deputy Crown
Prince of Saudi Arabia who's now the
Crown Prince of Saudi Arabia and as I
understand the story you went in and in
one hour you convinced him to invest
forty five billion dollars no no it's
not true okay
forty five minutes forty five billion
dollars okay sorry 1 billion dollars per
minute
it certainly wasn't as controversial
until late 2018 when the Washington Post
journalist Khashoggi was murdered by
Saudi agents and that suddenly put a
spotlight on softbank's dependency on
Saudi money truth be told it didn't seem
to have stopped a lot of companies from
taking their money I think the amazing
part of the vision fund story was how
quickly it all came together from the
first talk of the idea to raising the
money to spending the money it's been
just a couple of years so as of last
count there are 88 portfolio companies
division fund more than ten billion
dollars was invested in DD a Chinese
ride hailing app uber took about seven
point seven billion some four billion
dollars went into we work another three
and to grab Southeast Asian ride-hailing
company so the idea is you have so much
money that anybody even thinking of
competing with you just looks at the
size of your checkbook and gets scared
and doesn't even try and he does seem to
have a particular weakness for very
charismatic and very fleshy founders and
in your item Numenor we work as a prime
example I mean Sohn himself loves to
talk about Jack Ma the founder of
Alibaba his best investment today he had
no business plan but his eyes was very
strong strong eyes he wants his founders
to be the next jack Mar to be crazier
than the craziest guy in the room the
vision
and let's not forget they had some
successes they were a big investor in
Flipkart
and Indian retailer that they sold
they've had some companies that have IPO
unfortunately there are some
high-profile investments that have just
lost tons of money we work being the
prime example they aren't making any
money they're far from making money no
one really quite understands it mrs.
model according to people with knowledge
of the discussion Softbank is concerned
about the valuation that we work could
get in the public market when we work I
pee oh so spectacularly imploded South
Bank essentially had to step in and
pretty much buy the company they came up
with a nine point five billion dollar
rescue package and now owned about 80
percent of the startup which essentially
makes it their problem to make them
profitable they had a fairly you know
credible plan for how this could happen
don't go at me though Dino time will
solve the we work problem we'll make
money once the we work building
portfolio is allowed to ripen how stop
the new building developments and the
profitability will drastically improve
and we can expect the cost to go down by
half or even more we work declined to
comment for this video about soft banks
investment in the company there are some
bits that I did just in retrospect seems
silly you know for example zoom the
company that wanted to make robot pizza
and then pivot it to revolutionizing the
the food industry and eventually it
basically crashed and burned probably
the best example of a sort of
self-inflicted injury is is oil this is
the company that came out of India
created a platform for hotels where
people could book a room and expect a
reliable service which was a
considerable feat for India and their
targets seem to have been just the the
raw number of rooms available on their
platform that is of last count they had
over 1 million rooms but they were
nowhere near profitability it's a prime
example of the kind of growth at all
costs and does come with vision for
money that could take a
good company and a good business idea
and essentially ruin it Softbank has
declined to comment on its investment
strategy despite some large and high
profile losses the vision fund actually
seemed to be doing okay last year
Softbank said that based on its analysis
of the companies in the vision funds
portfolio the fund was making money but
then 2020 happened churches shut down
world landmarks closed as more nations
report the spread of the disease
companies in the gig economy including
uber lyft
door - post mates and more are facing a
host of challenges relating to the virus
outbreak the vision fund is in a lot of
companies that have been hit so hard by
this pandemic so uber is one of those
it's had to lay off a lot of people
another company in a similar position is
oil coffee 19 is certainly going to be a
death blow for a lot of companies on
envision funds portfolio Sloane himself
has said that about 15 of them will go
bust but son still has confidence in the
funds bigger companies those large size
and besties are surviving and actually
doing steady they have a better chance
going through this valley of coronavirus
exception as we work you made a mistake
in investing in we work and I'd admitted
that several times I was foolish and
made the wrong decision you know I guess
some of the vision funds investment
practices have made it uniquely
vulnerable to the to the Cova pandemic
in part their heavy exposure to ride
hailing they invested in all the top
companies and it's by far the biggest
segment the fact that their companies
are geared for high growth and not
necessarily profitability Softbank group
says its vision fund lost 17 point seven
billion dollars in its last fiscal year
that's after writing down the cost of
bad investments the vision fund went
from soft banks biggest a profit maker a
year ago to its biggest drag on earning
some vision - I don't know seems like an
uphill battle for sure I think the real
takeaway from the vision fund is that
money really can't buy success that all
of that cash that huge checks that
Masayoshi Son was cutting actually
hurting the founders and the companies
in he was investing in more than they
were helping at first it looks like
having all that money allowed them to
burn cash longer to beat other companies
to survive longer but the problem is
that they were hiring a lot they didn't
have fiscal discipline and so in the end
all he was doing was creating bigger
bigger bubbles that were bursting and
collapsing and a much grander scale in
his past few months
Shaun often stood on stage and said that
he's learned the lesson but he's
actually quite short on details the
lesson he seems to have learned is that
investing in we work was a mistake it's
not at all clear if he learned the
lesson of the kind of hyper-girl
division fund has promoted maybe that's
what's his strength nothing will stop
him he's so determined he's so stubborn
he's got such incredible self-confidence
that really is his greatest gift he's an
incredible shine but at some point there
is gonna be a reality
[Music]
you
[Music]